>> Female Presenter: Hi, everybody. Thank
you all for joining us today.
Garance Doré began her career as an illustrator
living in
Paris. And in 2006, she began her blog Une
Fille Comme
Moi where she publishes her drawings and musings
about
life. Garance picked up a camera and began
adding
street-style photographs to her blog and the
rest as they
say is fashion history. So please join me
in welcoming
Garance to New York.
[Applause]
>>Garance: Hi.
>>Presenter: So Garance thank you so much
for coming here. We're
very thrilled to have you. As we'll discuss
later, we're
not necessarily known for our fashion sense
at Google.
So this is.
[laughter]
>>Garance: [laughing] This looks very good.
>>Presenter: Thank you. I know she's talking
about me. Not so
much some others. [laughter] So Garance, as
an illustrator, you came to
your blog as a bit of a fashion outsider,
some might say. And now, you
really positioned yourself, probably unintentionally,
as a really relatable fashion insider.
Can you talk to us a little bit about that
evolution and how that
happened.
>>Garance: Yes, it's a long story. But I try
to make it not too
long. I open my blog because I was frustrated.
I --
after studying communication and working as
a -- how do
you say PR in a cinema which was great but
not very
fulfilling for me. I had that thing like,
"I want to be
an artist. I'm frustrated. My life is okay,
but it's
just okay. My dreams --" and so, I was like,
"okay, I'm
26 or 27. It's the moment to do something,
because later
is going to be too late, which is not true,
it's never
too late. [laughter] But at that time, I was
like, "you have to do
it now." So I dropped everything. I had a
very good
friend support system, so I didn't really
feel alone. A
lot of my friends were artists and everything.
So I
started to teach myself illustration. That
was my dream.
I had that dream of me, my studio, big windows
and like
illustrating all day. And so, of course in
the beginning
my illustrations went horrible and I didn't
get any jobs
and everything. But little by little by training
myself
and getting kicked out of magazines and like
editors and
everything, I ended up getting a few jobs
and started
like working. And I should have been happy,
but I
realized that my dream was not that cool.
I mean, I was
actually like alone all day, because illustration,
even
if you have big windows which I didn't have,
is very
lonely job. And the thing is that I had to
send my
illustration to an artistic director. The
artistic
director would tell me, "Okay. This lady looks
good, but
can you make her top more pink and her boobs
bigger. And
that like this and she should be smiling."
Because I was
not yet working for Vogue or anything. So
you know it
could be more commercial work. And by the
time I would
see my work printed in a magazine or a book,
it wasn't
what I wanted. I thought it looked horrible.
So I was
very frustrated. At that time, Scott the Sartorialist
--
I didn't know him at that time, I knew that
blog and I
was fascinated. Because first I had never
been to New
York. At that time I was not living in Paris.
I was
living in the south of France. And I felt
very -- the
only connection I had and at that time there
was really
no Internet. The beginning. The only connection
to the
world was like through magazines. I would
always buy.
like, a lot of magazines. Lots everywhere.
So I was
watching that, "oh my God, this is crazy.
What's
happening? I can be in New York. I can see
all these
cool people that" -- and it inspired me to
open my blog.
And so, what I told myself was, "I'm going
to give myself
a last chance." It had been like two years
since I
started dropping everything and started taking
on
illustration. This is going to be my chance
to talk
directly to the people without having an artistic
director changing my work. It's going to be
a last
chance to try -- I mean, at that time I was
taking too
long to illustrate. Like a week to do one
illustration.
Illustration in a magazine is like 200 Euros.
So, if you
take ten days to do that.
>>Presenter: Yeah, it's not a lot of money.
[laughter]
>> Garance: You're never going to get anywhere.
No big windows.
So I was like, "I need to learn to draw more
fast. I'm
going to open a blog and every day I'm going
to post
something. It comes the weekend, I'm going
to give myself
an hour because I have a life, you know, one
hour post on a
blog. Try to be closer to people that have
their real
feedback. And the only thing I told myself
was that I'm
not going to say I live in Paris. Because
[laughing]
Because going to Paris to show my book -- because
at that
time you would go with your book, you know,
your
portfolio. Going each time people were like,
"oh, nice
work; that's cool. We're going to call you.
Oh, you
don't live in Paris? [laughter] Oh, okay.
I'll call you. Bye. Never
call back. Because there was really that thing
like --
people, I think, even at that time we were
working with
e-mail. Because when I started we were still
working
with like scanning the stuff faxing the stuff.
Internet
was starting. Working through e-mails and
everything.
But they want to feel like you're here. You're
in the
same.
>> Presenter: Even the fact that there's technology.
>> Garance: You're in the same world as them.
I didn't know. I
didn't belong because I was far -- so I was
like no way. Totally
Parisian. So I was talking on my blog about
myself, never
mentioning you know how where I was living.
Everything
was a little vague. But you know. [laughter]
It worked out. And
so, but of course, so what happened is that
when I opened
my blog, I don't know -- it took off very
fast, because I
first started publishing just illustrations
and then I
realize I like to communicate and exchange
with people.
And so, I started publishing texts and like
three weeks
later a magazine called me and said, "this
is special.
We want to make a little story about it."
And so, I had
like a little story in a French magazine,
L'Express, which is pretty
big. And from that point, you know, I was
like
legitimate and people would come to the blog
and the
audience would grow. At that time I had like
readers.
>> Presenter: After three weeks? After three
weeks? That's extraordinary.
>> Garance: It was very, very fast. I think
what happened was that I was the first one
to do that mix of fashion and like
telling stories about my life at the same
time plus
illustration. And my blog was cute. It was
really like --
>>Presenter: It still is cute, Garance
[laughter]
>> Garance: But I really -- the design was
as simple as it is
today so that you could see the images. So
I think it's
a pleasure to come every day and see a new
-- you know
what? At that time blogs were like -- people
didn't
really care. That's a blog. She's going to
put that
image. With my -- you know -- and since the
beginning I
was like I wanted to look good. And so, I
think it's
easy to get. Even if they don't read, people
just come
and check and see there's an illustration
that's nice to see. So
it took off very fast like that. And it took
off in
France, because France was very early with
the blogging
thing. We really had the big movement. Looking
at
you because you're French. [laughter] And
so, there was that
movement where like ten, 15 bloggers and we
were called
fashion bloggers, just because we were women
and we were
talking about the things we talk about when
we're with
friends. And so, you know I was called a fashion
blogger. That's how it started.
>> Presenter: You and Scott -- so Scott Schuman
who, if you don't
know writes -- blogs The Sartorialist, which
is an amazing
blog here in New York -- based largely in
New York.
She's also in love with him. [laughter] That
smile is not just as a
fan of his work. You guys were really at if
forefront of
this. I think blogging has changed since you
guys came
on the scene. Especially fashion blogging.
There's a
lot of people who are chronicling daily outfit
choices.
So what do you think of that evolution. It's
really a
trend, if you can call it a trend since we're
talking about fashion, that you guys really
started.
>> Garance: Yeah, I think it's funny. For
a long time, I think
blogging was really about -- it was more like
forums.
You know where you want to communicate with
people and
share your stuff but not really make -- it
was not a way
to be famous. You know, it was not a way -- you
didn't
make money or be famous. It was more like
a way to
communicate and make a new circle of friends,
right. And
so, I mean, for a long time. My blog is like
five years
and a half. I think for like two years -- of
course I
started to see, like, I had, like, story in
a magazine and
another one. So I could see that there was
something
happening. But for a long time it was more
like -- it
was a community thing. And with Scott -- Scott
started
working on style.com and I started to work
with Vogue.
Things like that. And I think it became clear
that it
was a great way to make self-promotion and
at that time a
new generation of bloggers arrived who, you
know, would
more maybe think of how could I get myself
out in this world
which is cool, you know, but how can I show
my work, how
can I show myself? So that was a second -- how
do you
say?
>> Presenter: Wave.
>> Garance: Yeah, second wave of bloggers.
>> Presenter: So do you think that bloggers
such as yourself and Scott, with
the kind of influence that you've had in the
industry
which is quite tremendous and I'd like to
talk about that
in a minute, too. Do you think there's room
for bloggers
to have that type of influence again in the
industry -- in
fashion.
>>Garance: I'm sure there is. I mean, for
me it's just the
beginning. The only thing is that what is
interesting --
the fact that I come from that far away place
that is the
past. [giggles] And is that I really started
doing the blog for
reasons that were, like, I want to be free.
I want to be
able to talk freely. I want to be able to
share with
people that -- without the filter -- and Scott
was
exactly the same. I think he was frustrated
because he
would see those people in the street and what
he saw in
magazines was totally different. So he made
like that
>>Presenter: that connection
>>Garance: that link between the people that
were reading magazines. So
you could see -- there was really--it was
really
expressing something that was missing. Whereas
now I
think it's becoming a real business, right?
And so, I
think -- what I still feel that way. I still
feel like I
want to be in places where other people are
not -- so I
want to be where, you know, I don't care about
going to a
show and saying "woo, it's wonderful". I say
it sometimes
when it's great, but it's not my mission.
I mean,
magazines are here for that. Now other bloggers
do that
very well. But I really -- I'm not interested.
I don't
want to be bored by myself. I'm my first reader.
And
even if I'm invited to do stuff. Also because
I started
like when I was older, so I think I have.
>> Presenter: 26.
[laughter]
>> Garance: But yeah I opened my blog when
I was around 30. So
it's like I feel like I've been frustrated
long enough
that I don't want to fall back into that thing
and be
that blog where you go and you're like, "who
is she
talking for? You know, is she talking for
that brand,
that advertiser or whatever?" I'm really talking
for
people that are like me. I hope. That's what
I want to do what I
want to keep on doing.
>> Presenter: Do you think there's anything
particular about the
moment when you started, since it was really
at the forefront
of this whole blogging trend, that led to
your success or
sort of helped kind of propel you.
>> Garance: It's weird. We were trying to
talk about what I was
going to say today and earlier. And I was
like I think
the thing that I'm still not really -- like,
realizing,
you know, is that people get attached to a
personality.
For a long time I was, like, what do people
like about my
blog? Is it the writing? I'm very goofy when
I write. For me, I am not a writer.
Is it the illustrations? Is it the photo?
What exactly
is it? And I think now I have enough experience
that I
can realize okay maybe it's just a personality.
You
know, it's a big picture. It's like a little
bit of
everything. And so, I think that's -- this
and the fact
that my personality is being very easy. You
know, I talk
about any kind of women's problem and you
know, I don't
hide anything.
>> Presenter: You're very candid on your blog.
[laughter]
>>Garance: I'm not trying to say that I'm
perfect. And I think
that's what was missing. In magazines, I would
read
interviews of celebrities. Wow, she really
wakes up at
five and drinks water with lemon inside and
then she does
yoga before, you know, going.
>> Presenter: She doesn't exercise either.
[laughter]
>> Garance: Doesn't have weight problem and
then goes to get a
massage and then goes to work. I was like,
wow. But you
know, and I know that it's not my everyday
life. My
friend's everyday life. That's what I prefer
to do with
my friends is to talk about real life. That's
what I
wanted to do with my blog. That's what I wanted
to do in the
beginning because I thought I was talking
to nobody. I
thought I would never have a reader. So, okay,
I'm going to
talk like I talk to my friends, like I talk
to my sister.
And that's what I still do now. I think I
saw that the
audience was growing. And then, one day or
another there
was like "oh my God so many people are reading
me". And
then some people come there first time, "I
love your
blog". This is not possible. You read that
post the
other day when I was talking about the toilet.
[laughter] I was
like really? And or, you know, and so, I don't
-- I just
I'm very good at like putting blinders and
just, you
know, like today I didn't think about coming
to do a talk
before five minutes before and then I started
stressing a
little bit. I'm just like always thinking
I'm talking to
my friends. I'm talking to them. And that's
it. And I
think that makes a difference. I'm not taking
-- I don't
know. People are not an audience. They're
just -- I
feel like it's my friends.
>> Presenter: Well, so you've been creating
your blog, as you said,
going on six years now which really makes
you a veteran
of this format which is why you're dressed
in fatigues.
>>Garance: Yes, exactly
[laughter]
>>Presenter: How has blogging changed over
time for you in the past
six years.
>>Garance: Um
>>Presenter: Are you doing anything differently
apart from talking.
>> Garance: I'm doing a lot of things differently
because I want
to be better all the time. So each time I'm,
like, I'm
going to work less but be better. It doesn't
work like
that. I feel like I'm busy all the time. The
blog is
also -- you know, the success of the blog
brought me a
lot of work. So people call me to shoot an
advertising.
Shoot a video of this. There is a lot of things
happening every day. So I am very busy. But
I think,
you know, I'm trying to not change my vision
and I just
like trying to make it better. Like, you know,
the photo
for example. For a long time there was no
photo. There
was just illustration. Yeah, but I really
want to show
those shoes. So I took a camera and tried
and worked.
And so, I'm trying to make it better, but
I'm trying to
stay true to myself, which sounds very Queen
of Butter -- like really
like what I'm trying to do. And I love her..
[laughter]
>> Presenter: I love her too. She seems very
nice. I don't believe
that she eats all that stuff that she says
she eats.
>> Garance: I don't know what she eats. You
should tell me.
>> Presenter: That cookbook. She says she
eats all kinds of butter and I don't know
if I'd buy it.
>> Garance: The thing is she wakes up at five
to do yoga.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: All right. Some people are genetically
blessed in a
way that I'm not.
>> Garance: That's why we love her. She's
just a dream.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: Exactly. So you talked a little
bit about this that
people really relate to your personality.
Which I think
is really coming across even in this chat.
I think the way you are on your
blog is how you come across in person. We
have had a
chance to meet a couple of times in person
and it comes across very quickly. A lot of
bloggers kind of
emerged as personalities of their own. And
if you
contrast that to somebody like Bill Cunningham
which I
think of as the original sartorialist, riding
around on
his bike in the streets of New York, like,
very low key
except for that bicycle. With the documentary
about him which just came out.
People didn't really know that much about
him. So it's
such a contrast to the way you guys are working.
Certainly because of technology making it
easier to promote yourself
as a personality.
>>Garance: Absolutely
>>Presenter: But I would love to talk about
that a
little more. Bill Cunningham wasn't sitting
in front at
fashion week. But you and Scott and folks
like you are. That's really
changing the industry so much, giving that
relatable outsider, relatable insider, rather,
access in a way that's never been done before.
Can you
talk a little bit about that.
>> Garance: Yeah, there is two different things.
I think of first
I've always loved technology and my blog was
cute in the
beginning also because I knew HTML which sounds
weird but
I learned myself to do it.
>>Presenter: Do you want to work at Google?
We're hiring in case.
[laughter]
>>Garance: But I think the thing that even
still now fashion
trends. There's, of course, but like the audiences
on
Internet are crazy when you compare that to
the magazine.
It's like crazy. And I come from France so
our audiences
in France for magazine it's smaller than America.
It's
such a big country. But already at that time
when I --
before I left, I live in New York for a year
now and
before I left France, I was looking at the
-- you know,
the diffusion of the magazine. How do you
say how many
they sell and they print.
>> Presenter: The distribution?
>> Garance: Yeah, this is crazy. I have more
people coming to see my
website than this magazine, that magazine,
than most of them.
So I think this is the power of it. And you
know it's as
simple as that. You know, when you get there
and you're,
you know, able to talk to people directly
and have that
power -- I mean, I didn't -- it's funny because
for a
long time magazines came and said, "do you
want to work
with us? Do you want to be our web editor
in chief?"
Beautiful magazine and stuff. And for a long
time I
was like I have to do that. This is such a
great
opportunity for me. I will never have dreamt
of that in
my life before or you know, but each time
I was like you
know what? I feel like I have a better stuff
where I
am.
>> Presenter: Better platform on your own.
>>Garance: Yeah, I have my media. And again,
I was watching
their audience and I was like I can't leave
my
beautiful audience that I love and I've created
to go to
a place where there is less audience. And
it's not my
friends like and so, it was hard. I mean,
a lot of times
I was like, "this is the wrong choice, you're
wrong blah,
blah, blah". But now I understand it's very
important to
always follow what you feel. And so, I think
that's why.
I think the audience is very strong; there
is that and there is the power of
recommendation. I mean, for a brand. When
I talk -- how
many times did it happen when I talk about
a pair of
shoes and two days later they're out of stock.
I think that's a
mix of audiences and also the fact people
feel close to
me. So if I say "I love that" maybe it means
more than if
it's a magazine because they have the feeling
they know
me so I'm their friend.
>> Presenter: It's like getting a recommendation
from a girlfriend.
Versus from Anna Wintour [laughter]
Presenter: Not my friend but she seems very
friendly I'm sure.
>>Garance: I'm sure. She's friendly, yeah
>>Presenter: She scares the crap out of me.
I'm not going to lie. [laughter]
It's not like we're hanging out or anything.
But let's
talk about that. The blog is really -- we
can edit that
all right? I didn't mean that. She seems very
nice.
I'm sure she's. [giggling] But the blog has
really morphed into a
business for you. I mean, it's not just a
place to house
ideas and house your illustrations and your
amazing photographs and your musings on life
as we said
in the beginning. It's really become a place
where you
can influence trends, where you can sell out
a pair of
shoes.
>>Garance: Which is something you have to
be very careful with
I.
>> Presenter: Some people cannot handle that
kind of traffic.
>> Garance: Yeah exactly. You're like ha -- maybe
I could do that
and make money and you know oh just one day
or you know.
So I'm very careful with that.
>>Presenter: So how do you handle that? Because
I would imagine.
It was r it's a wonderful luxury of success.
>> Garance: Yes, it's luxury of success that's
why you have to
stay successful. [giggles] Basically, I just
say no and people are not very
happy when I say no. Now I think we're in
a great moment
where brands because it's what we're talking
about --
mostly advertisers or people who understand
that you
can't force -- I mean with Internet now--
you can't force
your product on the people, it has to come
-- it has to
be smarter than that. So now they totally
understand
when they say "can you do like edit content".
Which means
can you talk about my brand in your blog.
Like it was
from you. And I say this is off limits. I'm
not doing
that. The content of the blog is not for sale.
But I
can publish something on your blog or I can
-- we can use
that in a different way. They now start to
understand.
A year ago, they would say okay we're not
working with
you. Yeah.
>> Presenter: Wow.
>> Garance: Which is fine. I said okay, right..
>> Presenter: It's not the right partnership
for you, if that's the case.
>> Garance: Yeah exactly.
>>Presenter: No, I mean that important to
maintain that integrity
especially since you said most of your success
is based
on people trusting you.
>> Garance: Of course. That's the treasure.
And I hope that -- and I think
there will be other blog -- because now it's
become such
a business, you know, that, you know, I think.
My blog is
very egocentric. I'm always talking about
myself. But
in a way it's good. Because I'm not listening
-- I mean,
I'm listening to the readers when they want
to talk about
a subject, but I'm not -- you know, like,
I'm not
publishing something to have the most comments
or to have
my things re-tweeted a lot. Or -- you know,
it always
comes from "oh my God I want to buy that".
Or "I feel that
way. I want to talk about it". I don't try
to have my
content dictated by what the people want.
Or it's very
easy to stray and go in the wrong direction.
>>Presenter: And so, how does that contrast
with when you're hired
by an advertiser or, let's say, by a magazine
to create
content from them. How do you maintain that
voice that
people know you for but still fulfill that.
>>Garance: I always try to have a conversation.
And then
understand I'm very happy now that, if I don't
feel
something, I'm have the luxury of not doing
it. It's a
choice. You know, so I don't really care about
making
amounts of super-great money. I feel like
what I have
right now is wonderful. I think I'm more happy
expressing myself and taking pictures and
illustrating
than having stuff. So, you know, I'm also
-- I can say
no. It doesn't weigh on me. I don't have to
-- so, but
I try to have a conversation and see what
would be smart.
I also -- I think I'm good at consulting for
these brands
and tell them I've been working and I know
what's going
to be better for your brand -- I mean, not
your brand but the people you want to reach.
Tell me who you want to reach on the Internet
and I'll
tell you what's the best way for us to do
this and to do
that. And they're very happy usually because
this is so
new that, you know, you have to be, like,
now of course I
see young people coming out. I want to work
on Internet
and everything. But three years ago people
were like
working on Internet was not that good. You
prefer to be
in a magazine. Now people really want to do
it. So
there's still a lack. People are still looking
for
advice and feedback. And when you have your
veteran and [giggles]
you have so much experience, they listen to
me.
>>Presenter: So what sort of advice do you
give to a big brand.
Something that you're not going to get paid
for. I don't
want to take away from your consulting. [laughter]
What sort of big
problem do they come to you with? You sort
of think
through.
>>Garance: A typical problem I think -- different
for every case.
Most brands want to be cool and it's not easy.
So they
want to be cool, but they don't want to change
the way
they do. I think there are some brands who
-- you know,
it's interesting. You have to develop like
new
departments almost. You know, and I think
now there is
very good things happening, like, for example
I look at Kate Spade's Tumblr, for example.
It's interesting because they
really are able to tell. I think brands need
to tell
their story and to make people dream like
Ralph Lauren said.
He said, "I don't design dresses; I design
dreams". People don't really care about. They
can find the same
dress everywhere. And, you know, cheaper maybe.
And
everything so I think when you go to a store
what you
want is to buy a part of their cool and their
history and
what they are and who represents them and
everything.
And I think that's now taking care of a brand
is doing
all of that. Even myself I start to think
of myself as a
brand which feels very weird but you know
for a very long
time I was trying to keep all my content on
my blog.
People would say hey can you do that for us
and we'll
publish it on our website. And I was like
you know what?
If I do a content, --if I do a story or pictures
-- I'd rather put it on my blog so thank
you, no. But now with video that you share
and Twitter and Tumblr.
You can really spread the word and it's still
always
comes back to you which is pretty wonderful.
And I think
for any brand that's the idea. Give a precise
idea of
what is your dream? What is your dream you're
selling.
>> Presenter: So talking about technology,
how has technology in the
past five, six years changed what you do.
I mean, apart
from adding on a photography element which
is sort of
that more immediate element. Can you talk
a little bit
about that.
>>Garance: I think -- well, the video, for
example, is also a
good -- it's a good example because blogging
became easy
when platforms launched blogs that you can
do in two
minutes. And you know, it's always like the
technology
proceeds, you know, a revolution. Right now
people who
do film have the revolution of the 5g camera
and the
video that is beautiful like you're doing
a movie for
almost nothing. And so, you're seeing more
and more
beautiful movies and that's really. So that's
good --
and I started doing that. I didn't even know.
I bought
my camera. It was a new version of my camera
and
suddenly I switched it to video and I was
like, "oh my
God; this is wonderful". And started filming.
And put it
on my blog. And now people call me to shoot
ads. [laughter] It's
like I always think. Just I love to embrace,
you know,
what's new and try it. Sometimes it takes
me awhile.
Like I don't know; now I'm doing Instagram
for example.
For a long time I was going around it looking
what should
I do. Do I have time to do that. But you know
like I
never say no. I think it's the moment where
you become
boring, when you say "oh no, that's my thing.
That's how I do it." I always
change. I like to try something new. Like,
last fashion
week, I was doing my thing and just doing
my thing-thing
is like so I was going to the shows, taking
pictures of
people outside the shows. Of course everything
has
changed so much now. It's very different.
And I was
like "I'm bored." [laughter] "I'm bored."
And so, now we're looking for new ways
to show fashion week. I want to cover it in
a different
way. I want to be excited all the time. When
I am
starting to be bored, I don't even imagine
how the people
who read the blog must feel. If I'm bored
myself, what are
they going to feel? So it's going to be a
new fight, but
I love that. Maybe it's going to take me five
more
fashion weeks to figure out how to show it
in different
way.
>> Presenter: It challenges you on creativity.
>> Garance: Always, all the time
>>Presenter: What's next? On that point, fashion
week is right around the corner.
>> Garance: Yes, so. [chuckles]
>> Presenter: You're ready in your fatigues
to hit the main streets
of fashion.
>> Garance: I always have wonderful ideas
every morning and then
making them happen is, you know, so yeah I
mean you know
for new fashion week I would love to do more
video.
That's really I think how I'm going to get
excited and
then go a little bit outside of that, you
know -- I don't
want to just report. That's the thing. I want
to tell
stories and I think what's more interesting
than seeing
video show is seeing how do we live our lives
when we
leave fashion week because it's really funny.
It's
crazy. Stupid things happen. After two weeks
of fashion
week, everybody is crazy because you lose
track of what's
real and what's not. If ewe break your heel
it's the end of
the world. [laughter] Things like that. I'm
okay to like show
that. I'm okay to show when I am totally desperate
because I end up being totally desperate each
time I end up crying in the third
week. Now I know, when that day happens, I'm
like "Ooh that's the day". And I
want to share that because on the blog I can't
really.
It's difficult to communicate that. And also
I think
fashion as a -- you know, if you can just
show what's
happening and not write -- because when I
write, it's
really my thoughts. So if I want to make fun
of somebody
or you know of a situation, it's, you know,
it becomes
very personal. But if you just show what's
happening, I
think it can be really funny.
>> Presenter: So people can make their own
fun or not.
>> Garance: [inaudible] Exactly.
>> Presenter: Okay, so we're going to do a
little fill in the blank.
I'm going to ask you. With whatever comes
to mind. No
pressure.
[laughter]
>> Garance: Are you trying to put pressure
on me.
>> Presenter: No.
>>Garance: Did you see her shoes?
[audience responds]
>> Presenter: Do you want to see my shoes?
I don't think they're on
camera. Those are cool.
>> Garance: I'm putting my new shoes but look
what you've got
>> Presenter: I now, I wore them.
>> Presenter: : Yeah, this is my shoes moment
more than anything.
Style is--
>>Garance: Oh, I have a good one because I
think I came up with
the idea. Sorry I talk too much. [laughter]
But I realize it's
when you just give up all the thing 'oh I'm
going to be
Audrey Hepburn style. It's when you just give
up all
that and start just putting together the things
you like.
Even if it doesn't make sense, it will become
your style.
>> Presenter: Like that.
>> Presenter: Anna Wintour is -- we're not
picking on Anna Wintour I have nothing but
love for her. Anna Wintour is--
>> Garance: I don't know Anna Wintour. I think
she's sweet. I've
talked to her once and I was very, very stressed.
Dead
stressed. I wanted to interview her and she
looked at me
and smiled and answered my question and that
was it.
>> Presenter: So she's curt.
[laughter]
>>Presenter: Carine Roitfeld?
>> Garance: She's adorable.
>> Presenter: Adorable?
>> Garance: Yeah, she is. Everybody that knows
her will tell you.
She sends me e-mails like "hey I saw your
blog; liked it".
>> Presenter: That's so cool. I don't know
what I would do if I got
e-mail from Carine Roitfeld. That would be
pretty neat.
>> Garance: I was like, "Hey Carine sent us
an e-mail this morning". Really she's -- she's
a
real inspiration because she's so natural
and so nice.
And then, you see her and she's like this
bombshell, so much style. I
rial like her.
>> Presenter: Mom jeans. Mom jeans are--
>> Garance: Oh, my God. That's a concept that
I discovered when I
came to America.
[laughter].
>> Presenter: You're welcome. Contribution
to fashion. You're welcome
[laughter]
>> Garance: You know when you were young,
because I'm a little bit
old. Because when I was young, old people
would not wear
jeans. But all those people who wear jeans
today, one day
they're going to wear jeans, right? I don't
know what to
say about it. I think it's a concept. Yeah.
Presenter: It's a concept?
[laughter].
>> Garance: It's like mom hair.
>>Presenter: What's mom hair.
>> Garance: So I was looking -- okay, this
is bad. I was looking
at the fashion stuff for some -- like ad campaign
thing -- and there was the new -- what's her
name?
Arizona Muse haircut. She has that haircut
and for some
reasons all the magazines put it back like
that. Like the new Isabel Marant ad has it
like that. And it
was like "what's up? Mom haircut?" It's like
a little bit
up here. Like, a little bit like when you.
>>Presenter: I'm worried about my hair.
[laughter]
>> Garance: We'll send you all an email with
the Arizona Muse haircut. It's mom hair.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: That's mom hair with her mom
jeans. She could start a
new trend.
>> Garance: Yeah.
>>Presenter: But it's going to be all the
rage.
>>Garance: She's not happy about that.
>>Presenter: New York style is....
>> Garance: It's a very eclectic. What's great
with New York is
that I don't even miss France because I have
so many
French friends. The world is here. So everything
--
it's wonderful.
>>Presenter: Ironic facial hair is?
[laughter]
>> Garance: What is that?
>> Presenter: It's just a New York thing.
You go to Williamsburg. Ironic facial hair,
you know, like a mustache that.
>>Garance: Ohhhhh, so ironic that --
>>Presenter: Ironic facial hair
>>Garance: I don't know. The whole hipster
thing.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: Yeah, exactly.
>>Garance: Talking about it right now in my
blog.
>> Presenter: OK, are you? OK, hipsters are--You
fed into my next one.
>> Garance: In Williamsburg.
[laughter].
>>Presenter: Katie Middleton is--
>> Garance: She is doing a lot of sports,
I think. She's very
tense. [laughter] She looks tense in all the
pictures I see her
walking. Don't you think? No really.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: She wears panty hose. I heard
from my office mate that apparently
she's bringing panty hose back.. I'm not happy
about this.
>> Garance: What is panty hose?
>> Presenter: Pantyhose, like nude stockings.
>>Garance: Oooooh.
>>Presenter: I know, right. I'm Indian, they
--
>>Garance: Is she gonna wear the open-toed
shoes?
>> Presenter: I don't now but I hope not.
I'm worried about this, but apparently there's
a rumor that nude panty
hose are back because of indicate Kate Middleton.
I didn't
know this until yesterday. For my people,
Indians,
they don't make nude panty hose in my coloring.
So this [inaudible] an
unwelcome fashion trend.
>> Garance: Go to the beach.
>> Presenter: Oooo. Interesting. If the whole
Google [inaudible]
>> Presenter: Fashion trend I hate is
>> Presenter: You now mine, obviously. Nude
panty hose. But
what's your most --
>>Garance: I hate? I don't hate any fashion
trend. It's weird. I don't know.
I'm thinking right now.
>>Presenter: You can come back to it.
>>Garance: OK
>>Presenter: Models eat, blank.
>>Garance: Not a lot. Yeah.
>>Presenter: Not a lot, OK
>>Presenter: My favorite show at the Collections
is--
>> Garance: Oh, Hmm. It's mostly -- like most
of the time, it's
Prada.
>>Presenter: I see. And the most surprising
thing about Google to me
is --
>> Garance: About Google? [laughter] The most
surprising thing about Google?
Is that I like it. I don't know -- it's like
it's. It's
the whole subject. Can you do the question
in a
different way. I'd love to talk about Google
but it's
like -- I don't know.
>> Presenter: What would you like us to change.
[laughter]
>> Garance: To be more pretty.
>> Presenter: We can't change the home page.
That's our thing.
>> Garance: No, but the Google plus and everything.
I think it could
be more like that you can -- like, I love
chrome because
I can put all my -- you know, I can make it
nicely
designed and everything.
>>Presenter: Be able to personalize, customize
Google plus.
>>Garance: I like the products and I try them
all and I think
it's -- there is a a great thing going on.
I like that
YouTube is looking better. For a long time
I didn't put
my videos on YouTube because I thought like
the reader is
just depressing. Now it's starting to really
look better. The page reads better. For me
it's
very important.
>> Presenter: It's very important here, too.
So I'm glad to hear that feedback.
>> Garance: Google plus is great and everything.
I think people
love when there is a place that looks nice
like my blog
[laughter].
>> Presenter: Okay, so before we turn it over
to Q and A, I just
wanted to get your fashion advice on some
things.
>> Garance: [laughing] I know you have some
things in your bags.
>>Presenter: I have props here. I feel like
Googlers and tech folks in general we kind
of get a bad rap for being not terribly well-dressed.
We're not
known for our fashion sense. Although I feel
like this
crowd is proving that wrong. The cameras can't
see it
but this is a well-turned out group of Googlers.
I feel
it's unjustified and I want to put these misconceptions
to rest right here. So I would love for you
to review some of our
typical fashion choices here at Google. [laughter]
If that's OK. [inaudible] Okay so first
off, we have -- our standard backpack, which
you know. [laughter]
>> Garance: This is not standard. It's like.
>> Presenter: Well, it's fancy.
>> Garance: Is it your backpack.
>> Presenter: It's my colleague's backpack.
I borrowed it for this
demonstration. It's good. It's handy. You
can put your
phone right there tell me what you think.
Be candid.
>>Garance: Should I say something? I like
backpack, but this one doesn't say anything.
I
think you should like.
>>Presenter: It doesn't say girl on the go?
>>Garance: No
[laughter].
>>Presenter: Tech girl on the go?
>>Garance: Tech girl on the go.
>>Presenter: Tech girl on the go. That's a
look.
>> Garance: It's just like people would turn
away from you..
[laughter]
>> Presenter: You think?
>> Garance: I almost don't want to think
>>Presenter: Interesting.
>>Garance: yeah
>>Presenter: Wait, I have more. Hold on. So,
when every Googler
starts, [laughter] we get a hat, because -- we
really do get these.
>> Garance: Oh my God.
>> Presenter: What do you think.
[laughter]
>> Garance: I don't know what to say. Umm.
That.
>>Presenter: It has Noogler on it. Nooglers
means "I'm a new
Googler."
>> Garance: Oh, that's so cute. I was saying
about Google doing more pretty stuff.
>> Presenter: Isn't that cute? You don't think
this is pretty? This with my
backpack? You don't think I can rock this
look? [laughter] Really?
The fashion runways of Paris.
>> Garance: Sense of humor is very important.
>> Presenter: Yeah, we do have a sense of
humor. Some people may
not think we're funny.
>> Presenter: Okay, then obviously these are
taped up, in advance.
>> Garance: OK, these, I totally love.
>> Presenter: These are kind of cool, right?
I borrowed these from
my colleague Matt and I don't think he's getting
these
back. Without the tape.
>>There is something written on the side that
sounds funny
>> Garance: Optimize your life.
[laughter]
[laughter].
>>Presenter: I don't know. I just work here.
I think these are
kind of cool, right?.
>> Garance: What you should do is take out
the lenses.
>> Presenter: Why?
>> Garance: You pop the lenses. Because then
you become a
hipster. [laughter] Then nothing.
>> Presenter: Take my tape off?
>> Garance: You can keep the tape. Take out
the lenses. And then
that's cool. They're really cool.
>> Presenter: Even though it says optimize
your life on the size.
>> Garance: It's ironic.
>> Presenter: It's ironic. Okay. Well, that's
all I have. Thank you for those
tips. Does anyone have any questions. And
I'm going to
have to repeat your questions, because we
don't have a
mic for the audience. Yes?
>> Female #1: [inaudible].
>>Presenter: What are your top tips for new
fashion bloggers.
>>Garance: All right. So I think I gave a
little bit of that
before, but I think aesthetics is very important.
I
think now it's caught on. A lot of people
try to do
their blog looking good. I think, you know,
try to think
of what you have to say -- like, what is your
message?
What do you want to say to the people that
are going to
read you? And try to really -- in the beginning,
don't
try to make it too fast, too big. You know,
I think it's
very important to fail and to do some crappy
stuff and
like then decide, "okay, I'm not going there."
Just like
give yourself time -- say, three months. It's
not a long
time to try things and find your voice. It's
very
important, because people want to have a blog,
but they
don't know what to say. So just try to find
that.
Sometimes it can be pretty surprising. You
think, "oh,
I'm going to be a fashion blogger." And end
up talking
more about food. It's really important. I
think the
media itself will give you something surprising.
So let
yourself be surprised. You need anything more?
Then I
think you can engage with the people who comment;
like,
answer them and everything. I think it's very
nice. And
I try to do it still now even if I have not
a lot of time
and a lot of comments. So I think it's important.
>> Presenter: That's great. Anybody else?
>>Female #2: What's your relationship like
with new designers?
>> Presenter: The question was, "what is your
relationship like with
new designers?"
>>Garance: I am very interested in new designers.
But I am also
very tough, because I think a lot of new designers
get a
lot of credit because they're new designers.
And so, I
try to see through that thing. And really
-- I know that
it's difficult to put up a collection when
you don't have
a lot of money because it's the beginning.
But what I
look for is something that will appeal to
me. You know,
and now and in ten years, not just because
it's a young designer. Yeah. I
think that's my relationship with -- yeah.
>> Presenter: Any other questions? Yes ..
>>Female #3: How has moving to New York changed
your perspective
and maybe what you write about.
>>Presenter: How has moving to New York changed
your perspective
and maybe what you write about on your blog?
>> Garance: It's really changed so much. I
think it's just the
beginning when I realize -- I think what is
the most
important is the way people think is so different
than in
France.
>>Garance: In the beginning you're like, "oh,
it's the same; we're such
a global culture and everything." But then
you come here and everyday I
have to adapt to a new thing. The whole challenge
is to
restate myself, to hold on to the few things
that make me
French, but still live here and be part of
it. Lots of
change. Really. I could start to say, but
there is so
much. I'm very happy to be here. I feel like
much more
open to the world. It's very important.
>> Presenter: We're glad you're here.
>> Garance: Thank you.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: Anybody else? I think I saw
some more hands. Yeah.
>>Female #4: [inaudible].
>> Presenter: If you didn't live in New York
or Paris, where would
you want to live?
>> Garance: That's a very difficult question.
I think London, but
just because I was born in a very small island.
Took me
a long time to get to Paris. And as you know
I didn't
even -- it was a complicated move. [chuckles]
I didn't tell you how
it happened, but maybe next time. And when
I realized
how fantastic it is to have everything here
under your
hand, you know, and being able to meet the
people. It
would be very difficult for me to go back
to a smaller,
less international place.
>> Presenter: Yeah?
>>Female #5: [inaudible].
>> Presenter: So what's the direction in fashion
blogging that
really excites you and what's the thing that
leaves you
less excited was the question.
>>Garance: I think what's fascinating right
now is the Tumblr system.
I'm looking at it every day and I'm like taking
in all
those images and I wonder how people are driven
to do
this kind of blogs that are not really blogs
because it's
not even their content. They're just sharing
and
everybody's happy like that. I don't know
what it means
and what's really happening with that. There's
a lot of
fashion blogs that are Tumblr and everything.
But I
think it's pretty interesting to get to a
place where
everybody can have a place on the Internet
and put
something there, because it's so easy to get
the content.
>> Presenter: It's almost like everyone is
an editor.
>>Garance: exactly
>>Presenter: They can edit
their own.
>> Garance: It's very interesting. I'm pretty
excited also
because I love -- have the feeling to be drunk.
I'm
looking at all and there is -- when I go down
the page
there is more images coming. And I love that
feeling.
What makes me less excited is that I would
be
disappointed in the future if fashion blogging
and, you
know, I don't know so much for the rest, became
really
like magazines. I think it's -- I love magazines,
but I
think it's good to have a different thing
when you come
online and I think right now with the great
work that
fashion runs are doing and everything it becomes
a little
more like you have the feeling you're reading
a magazine.
You don't really know where the person stands
and if they
really love the product or if -- I am really
fighting I
mean for myself of course but I really hope
that we will
still be able to have places where we feel
that it's not
commercial or -- so I'm more worried about
that. And for
us, it's more difficult, because of course
I'm trying to
defend my freedom, but more -- everybody's
doing it so
people are like, "why don't you do it? Why
don't you do
it like that? We did it with that person with
that
person." I'm like, "well, not with me." That's
a little
bit scary for me.
>>Presenter: Anybody else? No? Oh, sorry.
>> Male #1: What do you think about men's
fashion? Like Paris and
New York -- men are really interested in fashion
and you
think like there should be more blogs about
men's
fashion.
>>Presenter: The question was about men's
fashion and what you
think about men's fashion and whether you
think there
should be more blogs about men's fashion.
>> Garance: Yeah, you know I'm very close
to Scott who does a lot
of men's fashion. I think it's great. I mean,
right now
I'm actually like on tumbler. There's a lot
of
interesting men's fashion blogs. There's a
few magazines
that are very interesting. I think guys are
getting --
because I think right now. I don't know how
to say it so
it looks -- but there is a way. Like, to be
a -- there
is a very, like -- I don't know. Like fashion
is not just
like gay men. It's difficult to say that without
appearing terrible. But you know you can be
a real guy
and love fashion. And for a long time, it
was not --
because you would put a magazine and it would
be naked
guys and I know that for my boyfriend, they
don't want to
really see that, right? It's like -- it was
difficult to
buy a men's magazine or look at and see that.
And then,
you had of course like -- I don't know in
France like
where you had a naked girl. I think we're
a little bit
past that and I think Scott has done a lot
to change
that. We see that now it's Pitti in Florence.
It's a men's show
and there's a lot of like -- lot of things
happening
around it. A lot of publicizing. I think it's
a great
moment for men's fashion. Don't you think.
>> Male #1: I don't know. I think it's kind
of slow. For
example, like at Google.
>> Presenter: I just wanted to repeat this
for the camera. He's
saying that at Google. He's about to give
Google as an
example of men's fashion -- which is just
funny. Oh, as a counter.
[laughter]
>>Male #1: [inaudible] a shirt, a tie, some
shoes. Shoes that tie, that look like actual
shoes. I don't know like I think it's like
taking a lot of time. I agree with you but
I don't know.
>>Garance: Well, I think it's more like you
have to find your
sources still. You have to find, you know,
go on
Internet and try to find those ten what sites
are
actually. But you know Mr. Porter I think
is really
cool. And really talks about men and how,
you know, so I
think there is a lot of things to see and
then to live it
in your own way. It will take some time for
guys to
really, you know, be at Google, for example,
and talk about
fashion really.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: Take a long time. Maybe that's
a niche for you to
start. A little unsolicited job advice.
>>Garance: I have to say it's very -- men's
fashion has been very
inspiring for me lately more than women's
fashion almost.
I love what's happening.
>>Presenter: Yes?
>> Female #6: I think you just talked about
this. I was going to ask you to kind of stay
on top of the fashion market,
there are so many resources and so many -- a
lot of
commercials. Hopefully some niche sources
out there. What are your
top line two or three tips -- just to stay
on top of the
fashion show.
>> Presenter: So the question again for the
camera -- there are so
many resources out there for fashion information
and what
are your top two or three tips for how to
do that -- some
niche resources and some more mainstream resources.
>> Garance: I think I just gave up the idea
of staying on top of
it because there is so much. And I don't feel
like it's
my mission to be on top of it, fortunately.
So, I go with
the flow. When I want to read about it, I
look. But I
think -- and there is a lot of websites that
do that. Be
like Fashionologie. You can find the information.
But
was your question about really staying on
top of that
information or staying on top as a fashion
blogger?
>> Female #6: You know, I'm actually interested
in both. More of like a
general question. If you go to like the pubs,
do you look at Vogue or WWD?
>> Garance: I look at what's interesting to
me. And I really
don't try to say I have to do that. I should.
I should,
of course, read women's wear daily every morning.
But
sometimes I just don't feel like it. And I
think I am
not a reporter. I consider myself more as
an artist.
And so, an artist doesn't need to be on top
of the
information, but more, you know, say what
he feels. And
I think that's more my mission. And if I started
talking
about fashion news or really think that I
need to report
on all that. That would be really boring.
First of all
because I'm not a journalist and I would do
it in in the
wrong way and second because you can find
that everywhere
now. So that's my answer. [laughs] I'm not
on top of it.
>> Presenter: Any last questions?
>> Female #7: Have you considered or are you
considering becoming a
designer? Because you have so much taste about
what's
good or not. So why not.
>> Presenter: So the question is have you
ever considered being a
designer?
>> Garance: No, I haven't. I think a great
part of becoming, you
know -- I don't know who I am now is saying
no to some
stuff. And I think you have to pick your battles.
And
you know like I love communicating. Being
a fashion
designer, you know, I really respect that
work and I
think it's a lot of learning and a lot of
failing and a
lot of -- and so, I would never -- maybe I
could do like
a little stuff, because I really feel I should,
but.
>> Male #7: Not your line.
>> Garance: Yeah.
>> Presenter: Well, Garance, thank you so
very much for being here
and please come back.
>> Garance: Yes, I will.
[Applause]
>> Garance: Thank you